i didn't grow up in a family like that
like birthdays you get
nothing not a big deal yeah yeah you
don't want that man though as a man over
when you get over like say 35 yeah what
is your birthday
right like nobody cares and even even i
would say like i would say
25 dude check this out and when you're
in a relationship
heaven forbid i want to do nothing
on my birthday correct okay yeah because
when it's your birthday it's actually
their birthday yeah
because they want to like you know why i
planned a day for us
like what is it my day is a lot of work
or throwing a birthday party i'm like i
don't want to be a [ __ ] party
i broke up with a very hot girl because
she she went like this we were at dinner
and she goes
i make a really big deal over my
birthday
they're just like oh no see ya
that's a red flag right there you want
me to make a big deal that's what
they're doing i also don't know how to
make birthdays great some people are
really good at like
they release doves and like uh he comes
in and uh
shining okay can i give you a little tip
here not that you need it but i'm gonna
give you a little little griffin advice
right here
you just need to know what's important
to them
no matter how big or small yeah you know
no matter how big or small it is
yep i remember a long time i go going on
a date like a
it was like and this the girl says uh
she missed
playing bingo with her grandma from
their hometown
she just me she said i missed it yes i
missed your grandma
but you know what i did on the first
date took a bingo to play bingo
and you dressed up like grandma
oh my god
grandma she don't know this is
terrifying check this out there's a wig
bingo ain't a good neighborhood knife
but what i'm saying was like no way
papa's doing bingo you don't have to
like
what should i do this big expensive no
you could just be like maybe she's in
the
[ __ ] elephants and you you know you
got like a little elephant thing
you know what i mean it's just knowing
like well you are saying i think she
liked that you were thoughtful and you
remember you remembered that
my friend's wife freaked out because my
friend
uh took soap that was he took the soap
from under the sink and unwrapped it and
put it in trash
and had fresh bar soap so she thought
that was incredibly
incredibly thoughtful meanwhile dude ran
out of soap and he's like i just need a
[ __ ] soap
and she was like i can't believe you did
that yeah and she he was like
he was like you know i just wanted to do
something yeah sometimes yes sometimes
it's like my girl wrote me this i won't
give a father's day this
long i hate long text this long text
about how good of a dad i am
that's what i appreciate this love you
she's all that's it
i'm like it's father's day like what do
you wanna do respond back
like you got to give a state of the
union
it's my day like you're supposed to
acknowledge me i'm saying dude
that's a lot of sponsors you're not
sentimental at all
compared to you i'm [ __ ] i'm i'm clay
aiken you're not at all
i was i was i didn't have any family
i missed something i wanted to be late
no you are though you make birthdays and
stuff oh for my kids i go
all out man yeah big time i can't like
my girls like what do you want i'm like
i don't
i don't really need what do i really
want i want to roll like daytona
you're not going to buy me that like
i'll work for and i'll get it like the
gifts
just give me pictures of my kids and
frame it that's it like you just give me
pictures
that's it that's it yeah but you know
what we're doing though that you're
doing is like you have to
sometimes not receiving a gift is just
as selfish as receiving a gift or
wanting a gift i'm saying what do you
mean like like when you go to some place
and somebody
says hey i got this flow right yeah you
heard something i don't know but you go
like that
and you go like this you go oh no no
it's okay that's actually selfish yeah
that pisses them off you know it's like
you you need
being gracious and being like i'll take
this is
is a very as a form of being like for
sure selfless too for them because
that's why they're doing this
so you know you have to like find
something we have to compromise you know
they want to do [ __ ] for you so you had
to be like all right so what is it that
i i can tolerate that i really want
that'll make them happy
see i have still have regret i still it
hurts me because my ex-wife
she she she because i got you something
that you're gonna really love
and i was like awesome and i don't pay
attention to my surroundings
and i still feel bad about this
it was for my birthday and she opens the
garage and i go
to car i go where is it and she had
cleaned the garage she [ __ ]
cleaned and organized the whole which by
the way which by the way
she took her no no but by the way that's
annoying because you're like um
i got this organized that [ __ ]
like this and i was like and i was like
but i was looking for something and i
didn't
yeah i'm an idiot i didn't it didn't i
didn't see it here girl you crazy
made shelves and all that and i went i
went i go i go
where is it yeah you're looking for the
girl what and she goes
are you kidding and she was she was she
see she kind of like was so disappointed
in me like she was so like she worked so
hard on it and she went like this she
went
but i'll show you clean the garage i
felt so bad while she cleaned well guys
well she put like
he's telling an ex-wife story yeah
yeah i don't notice stuff like that man
but how many times does it i mean
they should understand they should
understand that i had a girlfriend above
me a huge banana tree
and put it in the corner and bought me a
new dog bed i remember this
ally and she was like she designed she
was an interior designer for calvin
klein
for all that so she knew her [ __ ] man
and she would i'd come home and
i'd have there'd be a big banana tree
and a new dog bed
i didn't notice man i just didn't
[ __ ] notice
and then i'd notice that but even that
you know what i mean